The second issue is versioning, which can be tricky.
As new versions of the components are released,
backward compatibility becomes a problem.
If you are a component vendor, you need to keep your customers up to date with
changing standards, new programming language releases, and enhanced features.
The question then becomes,
to what extent should you remain compatible with previous versions?
Think of the issue from the customer's point of view.
They have a working product.
It will cost them time and energy to upgrade to a new version of your component,
and there's a risk of breaking their system if they do so.
If they don't need the new feature that you are offering,
they're going to be reluctant to upgrade.
>From your point of view, however, this may mean you've got to maintain and
support a long history of previous versions at additional expense.
Moreover, if there are multiple components involved,
each with their own versions,
you have an explosion in the number of combinations you have to support.
What's a poor vendor to do?